McDonald is making moves people I know
that everybody loves stories about fast
food chains and McDonald's I don't know
exactly why mcdonald's particular but
everyone loves fast food stories so
McDonald's has made a couple
announcements over the last couple days
number one that they're big the list you
know you go there and you got all the
options up there it's gonna go down from
16 to 11 they're getting rid of a couple
burgers instead of four quarter pounders
there's only gonna be one quarter
pounder you're gonna have to deal with
it but even more importantly than that
they've announced that they're going to
be doing psycho create your taste which
is basically they're using the Chipotle
idea you know you go to chipotle you can
actually pick and you talk to a human
being and you can actually pick what you
want I want brown rice in a bowl with
the block and the you know the braised
beef or whatever it is blah blah blah
well McDonald is actually going to start
doing that they're not gonna be using
humans because we have to limit human to
human communication this is 2015 almost
uh they're going to be using touchscreen
things and you're gonna be able to
select and build your burger is your
chicken sandwich is your chicken nuggets
what else do they have a McDonald's I'm
not even sure their salad anymore I
think they thought that maybe this out
anyway point is I think this is kind of
interesting because I don't think people
go to McDonald's for that much choice
we're all are faced with Jillian choices
throughout the day and there is
something about these places I don't go
to mcdonalds that much fortunately here
in LA we have we have in and out burger
which they give you like four choices
and i love it i go in i got number two
and if i don't get no man even if I got
it wrong and I accidentally got number
four it's pretty close to number two but
I think part of what appeals to people
about this fast food stuff is you don't
have to make choices you look up and a
bright big thing and you see it and you
just grab it and that's it and now the
idea that you're gonna go into
McDonald's like they think it's gonna
make everything faster i really wonder
because you know they have that ford
model of people in the back I pump this
I squirt that I blah blah blah that
sounded kind of gross but it's kind of
gross um so I don't know that it's gonna
make anything faster maybe it will and I
do of course the idea of choice and you
go to a restaurant and get whatever you
want sounds nice right do it your way or
I guess that's burger king but I do
think there's something about fast food
that we want certain simple choices in
life life seems to be getting more and
more complex with all the technology and
also we're always staring at screens
think about how much time you stare at a
screen and now you're going to go to
McDonald's and scared stare at a screen
yeah I know you used to scare it's
they're too big I keep saying stairs
scare and sits there anyway that's kind
of interesting do you think we should
have choices at McDonald's let us know
in the comments below